[موسيقى]
وهنا التوب بتاعي هيتكلم على سؤال رئيسي
خلال العرض الموجود معنا النهارده وهو هل
الاحكام المسبقه
والصور غير المكتمله لها تاثير على
قراراتنا وبالتالي بيبقى لها تاثير على
حياتنا
تعالوا نسمع مع بعض قصه ميمي وتشوف بعد
العرض بتاع قصه اسلاميه هل هنقدر نجاوب
على السؤال ده ولا لا
بيشتغل كمثرى في شركه ليه النقل العام
بيشتغل في الورديه الاولى
بتبدا من بعد الفجر مباشره
في يوم من الايام
رايح الشغل
رجب الاتوبيس بتاعه يتحرك
في اول محطه من المحطات
الراكب طلع الاتوبيس
الحقيقه
الراكب ده كان مختلف شويه زي ما احنا
شايفين في الصوره كده الراكب ثاني
ركب
ركب الاتوبيس قاعد على الكرسي بتاعه
ميني راح عشان يحصل منه الامر
يتحرك للسمين ناحيه الراكب
واقرب منه لا ما فيش استجابه من الرجل
وانا راجع
الراكب يدفع الاجره
تردد انه يسال الرجل لان كل ما يبص للركب
اليه حجمه وعضلاته ومدامته
يعني يستنى شويه
يمكن وهو نازل يعدي علي ينفع الامر
المشكله ان في اليوم الثاني
برده
الاتوبيس وهو
في نفسه خط السير نفس الراكب في نفس
المحطه شاور
وركب الاتوبيس
لسه
عايز ياخذ القرار انه يروح ياخذ منه
الاجره
عمل نفس الموضوع قرب من الراتب ولكن
ما دفعش الاوبرا قرر الموضوع ده يوم
واثنين وثلاثه وكل مره لسه ميمي اول ما
يشوف شكل الراجل
ماء يتردد نوايسه
وكل يوم يمر
يحس بحاجه غضب
ويحس ان هو في حاجه مضايقه انه مش قادر
يكلم الراكب او يطلب منه الامر
لحد ما في يوم من الايام
قرر انه ياخذ قرار شجاع ويتحدى الصعاب
وياخذ موقف مهم
وراح على طول بعد الورديه بتاعته لمديره
في الشغل طلبه ياخذ اجازه لمده سنه
عشان يروح صاله جيم
ياخذ فيها تمرينات تقوي عضلاته عشان يقدر
بعد السنه
يتعامل مع اي راكب زي الراكب اللي بيقابله
في العمل
ياخذ الكورس المطلوب عشان يقوي عضلات
اخذ السلفه وراحت الصاله الجيم وقعد سنه
يتمرن لحد ما فعلا زي ما احنا شايفين
الصوره اللي على الجنب كده بقى عنده عضلات
وبقي قوي وقادر ان هو بعد كده يقدر يطلب
الاجره من اي راكب زي ده مره ثانيه
ومن حظه الحلو انه اول يوم استلم فيه
الشغل مره ثانيه وهو في الورديه بتاعته
قابل نفس الرجل والراكب طلع الاتوبيس لكن
المره دي مش زي كل مره
الاسطه ميمي كان عنده حبوب الشجاعه لانه
قادر يتعامل مع الراكب ده ومع
الدراسه بتاعته ان هو ازاي ما يرضاش يدفع
الاجره
على طول ناحيه الراكب وبكل عنف وبقوه قال
له هات الاجره
الراتب اللي احنا شايفينه قدامنا ده راح
واقف هو طبعا طويل
طبعا لو احنا مكان الاسترليني في الموقف
ده ايه هيبقى شعورنا
نشوف الشريحه الجايه
لا اللي قبلها
اللي قبلها
ايوه نشوف الشريحه دي
ونشوف برده
الاجابه على نفس السؤال اللي احنا بنقوله
هل للاحكام المسبقه
والصور غير المكتمله اثر على قراراتنا
كان في اسره رايحه تزور اسره ثانيه وعايزه
تجيب لها هديه
فرحت دخلت الجزار او محل الهدايا وطلبت من
صاحب المعرض انه يجيب لها بورتريه او صوره
لمنظر طبيعي
نفس الموضوع
الاسره اللي بتشتري البورتريه شافت ان
الصوره دي الوجه فتاه فرفضت تاخذ الصوره
في حين ان الصوره دي نشوف اللي بعدها اما
اقربه منها لقوها انها لمنظر طبيعي عباره
عن شجره
وفيها غصن للطيور وفيها طيور بتعشش في
الشجره
نرجع ونسال السؤال ثاني هل للصور غير
المكتمله
والاحكام المسبقه تاثير على قراراتنا نشوف
الصوره الجايه
الصوره دي زي ما احنا شايفين على الجنب
الشمال صوره كلب بيعض خروف لو احنا شفنا
الصوره دي لوحدها بالشكل ده ايه الاحكام
او الصوره الذهنيه اللي هتيجي على طول في
دماغنا اما نشوف هذا المشهد ان كلب
او
يموت خروف من قطيع احد الرعاه شعوره هيبقى
ايه ناحيه هذا الكلام
في حين ان انا لو بعدنا الصوره شويه او
شفنا الصوره الكامله
هنشوف شكل ثاني خالص وهو ان الكلب بينقذ
الخروف من الغرق
فايه القرارات اللي احنا هناخذها لو شفنا
الصوره دي
وايه القرارات اللي احنا ممكن ناخدها لو
شفنا الصوره
في نفس السياق تعالى نشوف الصوره الجايه
دول صورتين
لو احنا بنتفرج على نشره اخبار
ونشره الاخبار عرض الصوره الاولى بين
بنتكلم فيها عن حرب ما بين جهتين او صراع
مسلح
فالصوره الاولى بتقول حاجه
ممكن نفسرها وبناء عليها
ناخذ احكام عندنا وبناء عليها
الاستنتاجات ناخذ قرار
نفس الوقت لو شفنا الصوره الثانيه
بنفس الشخص ممكن ناخذ قرارات ثانيه في حين
ان الصوره ممكن تكون واحده ولكن ممكن
في الجزء ده لو احنا عايزين
الاستنتاجات بتاعتنا تبقى قائمه على دليل
معين وممكن نعرضها بالشكل ده لو احنا
عايزين اللي قدامنا نقنعه
باشياء معينه
وهنا نقدر نقول لما نحب نقنع حد بحاجه
طريقه الاقناع بتقوم على ان اقدم دليل
والدليل ده بخرج منه باستنتاج
والاستنتاج ده
بيطلع لي نتيجه والنتيجه دي اللي على
اساسها باخذ القرار
فمثلا
لو انا حبيت اقول
ان انا
صعيدي
ازاي صعيدي ان انا عايش في الفيوم
ومولود في الفيوم
والفيوم من اقليم السعيد اذا انا صعيدي
كلام ده صح ولا غلط
صح
طيب
لو قلت ان كل اللي بيشتغل في المستشفى
دكتور
اسامه بيشتغل في المستشفى اذا اسامه دكتور
الصحه الكلام ده صح ولا غلط
مين قال صح
الحقيقه الكلام ده غلط ليه غلط
لان المستشفى بيشتغل فيها تخصصات مختلفه
في الحسابات القانونيه وفيها
التمريض فيها كثير من المهن المساعده
ولكن انا عشان اقنع حد ثاني لو الدليل
بتاعي مش صح بناء عليه الاستنتاج ما يكونش
صح وبالتالي النتيجه هتكون مغلوطه
في نفس الوقت لو انا قدمت دليل صح
الاستنتاج هيبقى مرتبط بهذا الدليل وبناء
عليه هتكون النتيجه او قرار مرتبط
بالدليل نفسه
وده الموضوع اللي
بيقوم عليه او بيناقشه كتاب اسمه المغلطات
المنطقيه لمؤلفه الكاتب دكتور عادل مصطفى
هي الكتاب بيقدم من خلال فصوله مجموعه
كبيره من المغلقات المنطقيه اللي بتقوم
على اساس الاقناع القائم على استنتاج
والاستنتاج ده قائم على دليل ولكن هنا
الدليل اللي بيخلي الانسان بيقتنع سواء
كانت هذه القنوات مضبوطه او حقيقيه
وعشان كده احنا بنتكلم ونقول اننا لازم
نتعلم هذه المخالفات المنطقيه لانها بتفرق
كثيره في حياتنا
لاننا بكل بساطه ممكن لو احنا ما نعرفهاش
نمر التجارب كثير يضحك علينا من خلال
مرورنا بهذه التجارب لو احنا ما تعلمناش
هذه المخالفات المنطقيه
والكلام ده طبعا مش هنتعلمه لا في مدرسه
ولا تعلمناه في الجامعه ولا هنتعلموا في
اي حته ثانيه ولكن عشان نتعلمه لازم ندور
عليه بنفسنا ونغرب نفسنا ونستفيد منه طيب
الموضوع ده بالذات اللي هو الغلطات
المنطقيه عامل زي
العمليات الحسابيه
اي واحد فينا عشان يتعامل مع
الحياه لازم على الاقل يكون عنده اساسيات
للعمليات الحسابيه
عشان يقدر ان هو يشتري
حاجه من سوبر ماركت او يحاسب على وجبه في
مطعم او يعمل اي عمليه من العمليات لازم
يبقى عنده العمليات الحسابيه الاساسيه
والا ممكن يضحك عليه بسهوله
واعرض لكم من خلال الدقائق المعدوده اللي
جايه مجموعه من الاخطاء
المخالفات المنطقيه او الاشرار منها
ناخذ اول
حاجه وهي الاحتكام الى السلطه او الاحتكام
الى القوه يعني على سبيل المثال
لو مجموعه منكم في المحاضره الدكتور دكتور
الجامعه قال لمجموعه من طلابه ان شركه
تويوتا بتنتج اكثر العربيات امانه في
العالم
فبالتالي اصبح كلام الدكتور مسلمه واصبح
بالنسبه للطلاب ان عربيات تويوتا هي اكثر
السيارات امانه على مستوى العالم
النقطه الثانيه هي الاحتكام الى الشعبيه
لو حد قال لك ان
جهاز ايفون هو الاكثر مبيعا اللي بيحقق
اكثر مبيعات على مستوى العالم
يبقى اذا
الاستنتاج اللي هاطلع به والنتيجه اللي
اطلع فيها ان جهاز ايفون هو الاكثر شعبيه
على مستوى العالم اذا هو الافضل على مستوى
اجهزه المحمول
الاحتكام الى القديم
كلنا كلنا بذور ممكن تكون الجذور دي في
الريف او الصعيد وكلنا بنعتز بجذورنا
ودائما الناس الكبار اباءنا وامهاتنا اللي
يعني بيحبوا الرجوع الى الجذور معظم
كلامهم بيبقى قائم على حكم الجدود فنلاقي
الاب او الام وهو بيقول لنا حكمه دايما
يقول جدتي
فلو احنا
بنتكلم مع احد الجدود
وقالوا لنا ان لازم نحط
كف اليد الازرق ده على البال
وبنلاقي كثير من البيوت
واحنا خارجين من الباب معلقين يا العين
الزرقاء يا كف اليد الازرق ده ليه لان كف
اليد الازرق بيطرد الشياطين
فبالتالي اصبح بالنسبه لنا مسلمه بتقول ان
الكف اليد الازرق بيطرد الشياطين
الاحتكام الى المنشا
بنلاقي كثير في حياتنا لما نيجي نشتري
حاجات بندور على الحاجه المستورده ليه لان
المستورد ده نظيف فبالتالي لما اقول لك
انا شاري الشنطه دي او انت تقولي لي انا
شاريه الشنطه دي صناعه محليه تبقى حاجه
ايه الكلام انما لو قلت لك دي مستورده
يبقى حاجه نظيفه
لو انا قلت لك ان
عايزك تثبت لي ان في كائنات فضائيه عايشه
في العالم
يبقى اذا في فعلا كائنات فضائيه موجوده في
العالم
طب لو انا حبيت اقول لك اثبت لي ان في
كائنات فضائيه موجوده في العالم وانت ما
قدرتش تثبت ده اذا يبقى ما فيش كائنات
موجوده في العالم
الحالات الفرديه
لو انا قلت لك ان السجائر بتجيب سرطان
لكن انا عمي بقالي 40 سنه بيدخل السرطان
اذا السجائر
لو انا قلت لك وانا رايح مهرجان
حاولت اتصور مع احمد السقا فرفض ما رضيش
يتصور معي
يبقى الممثلين كلهم مغرورين
الاحرام
يا ابيض يا اسود
بروح مول كبير وانا بحبك يبقى لي في الاخر
يقول لي
لو بتحب الخير انت بتحب الخير
فلو انت
ما تبرعتش في الباقي يبقى انت بتحبش الخير
طيب لو قلت لك في جمعيه لحقوق للحيوان
عايزينك تتبرع بها 50 جنيه ولا ما بتحبش
الحيوانات طيب انا كده باقول لك لو انت ما
تبرعتش يبقى انت عدو الطبيعه وعدو
الحيوانات
هنا بقى في نوع من الاسئله اسمها اسئله
الادانه
التدخين بسؤال
الشحن
بشحنه اللي هو ايه اللي هو كده كده اجابتك
فيها ايه دانه مودان من ناحيتين سواء قلت
نعم او لا
واحد عدى على صاحبه في القهوه
وهو بيقابله على القهوه بيقول له
هو انت لسه بتضرب امراتك
فلو صاحبه رد عليه
طيب انت لسه بتضرب مراتك
ورد عليه لا ده معناها ايه
انه كان بيضرب امراته بس دلوقتي
التحكم بالالفاظ
ازاي ممكن اثبتك عشان هدف معين
انا عايز اقول لك
ان انت بالذكاء اللي ما تفوتش فيه الفرصه
دي مش محتاجه اقول لك ان انت شخص زيك ذكي
ما يفوتشي الشقه دي من تحت ايده لان الشقه
دي نقطه ولو ضاعت منك هتخسر كثير
ليس امريكي اصلا لو انا قلت لك كل
الامريكان اغنيه
وبعدين انا قلت لك بس انا قعدت مع واحد
امريكي
وكان بيشتكي من الفار اقول لك اه كلامك
مضبوط اصل انت اللي قعدت معه ده ما كانش
امريكي اصلا
القناص
عزه بتيجي بدايه كل سنه وتروح قايله 40
تنبه يجي واحد فيهم يضرب بالصدفه تطلع بقى
عزه في كل القنوات وفي كل حته بعد كده طول
النهار
الرينجه الحمراء ودي كانت طريقه بيستخدمها
النصوص عشان يشتم بها كلاب المراقبه بتاعت
الشرطه عشان يهربوا من الشرطه والكلاب
اللي كانت تبعهم بيبقى معهم رنجه تجري
وراءهم الكلاب يروحوا مين الرنجه في شارع
اللي هم في شارع الكلاب
اللي انت عايزه
الشماعه ودي اخر محطه من المحطات وهي
محمود اشترى
احمد اشترى بدله جديده
هتاكل منك حته ايه الشياكه دي يا عم
فيبقى محمود حسن احمد
الوقوف على الحقائق لو كانت الاجابه يبقى
الرساله وصلت شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]